the end is near credit run from it dusty
still alive
the best thing about marble every single
movie has set the chessboard up for this
really tense standoff each character has
an environment that they fit in and it's
nice to move some of those pieces around
a fairly lucky that I got to be the one
to go and infiltrate Wakanda Kat opens
the door in the childhood heart it was a
place where he can trust outsiders
should we bow yeah he's a kid what are
you doing we we don't do that we're
seeing what Wakanda can bring to the
Avengers they need support and help to
deal with a very major global threat and
of course what Conda and will condoms
are the best to partner with you walk on
down now this is the place where we
should rally then try to win this is a
pretty amazing universe it's just huge
as the Guardians as Thor and his people
you know there's people from Wakanda is
everybody's just gathering together to
defeat an enemy it's pretty awesome so
good on what kinda good on us yeah we
don't fight for one life
people back in fact for all of them